Waiters and waitresses take orders and serve food...
...in restaurants, coffee shops, and other establishments.
The quality of service they deliver helps determine whether or not the patron will return.
That's because service sells.
The food may be completely ordinary,...
...but if the waiters and waitresses are friendly and attentive,...
...customers will come back again and again.
Job opportunities can range from local diners to national chains...
...to expensive restaurants in major cities and resort areas.
The key to success is always the same:...
...put yourself in the customer's shoes.
Tips are a major share of the take-home pay of a waiter or waitress,...
...and the ones who receive the biggest tips...
...are the ones who make their customers feel special...
...by anticipating their wants and needs before they have to ask for anything.
In addition, depending on the type of restaurant,...
...waiters and waitresses may perform additional duties...
...that are generally associated with other food and beverage occupations,...
...such as escorting guests to tables, setting up or clearing tables,...
...or operating the cash register.
Waiting tables isn't just about serving food; it's about serving people.